wind gusts of around 140 kilometers an
hour are fueling the flames in the heart
of California's wine country the fire
began Wednesday and is only 10 percent
contained
putting people and property at risk
dozens of structures have burned to the
ground
we've got rates of spread that are
extremely dangerous at this point with
erratic fire behavior and nearly 200,000
people have been advised to leave home
the largest evacuation the county has
ever seen but the California Highway
Patrol closed parts of a main evacuation
route Sunday morning due to zero
visibility and there's growing concern
the fire will cross the highway to an
area that hasn't seen fires in decades
and as a result is covered in dense dry
vegetation that area hasn't seen any
fire history since the 1940s so the the
fuels in that area are extremely dense
they're extremely old and decadent and
they're extremely dry the so called
Kincaid fire along with the TIC fire in
suburban Los Angeles are the biggest of
several blazes plaguing California
during its traditional wildfire season
when high winds and low humidity make
for hazardous conditions the impact
stretches far beyond evacuation zones
California's Pacific Gas and Electric
the utility company is cutting power to
nearly a million homes and businesses to
minimize the risk of powerlines sparking
additional fires as many as 3 million
people could be affected the company has
already filed for bankruptcy in the face
of lawsuits from last year's wildfire
season while this year's may just be
getting started Kristen salumi
al-jazeera